I'm gonna talk about clustering data a
guide for the perplexed
so I'm John Healy this is Leland
McKenna's or both mathematicians and
researchers from the Tut Institute for
mathematics and computing in Ottawa
Canada you can get to us on Gmail or
addresses are right there let's start
off what is clustering so clustering
sounds straightforward we find groups of
data that are all similar easy to say a
little bit hard to do and it tends to
mean different things to different
people so over the course of this talk
we're going to make that a little bit of
a more concrete statement so what it
means typically depends on your
application so there are lots of goals
that people might use clustering to do
you might want to use to partition your
data say you're on an HPC or distributed
computing system and you want all of
your data to live on a separate drive or
in a separate location then you need to
partition it and probably want balanced
partitions across that space maybe you
want to summarize your data you want to
explore your data you want embed it into
a vector space you can use other machine
learning algorithms you want to find
patterns within your data lots of
different reasons to cluster which leads
to lots of different clustering and
definitions so the keys there where we
find groups of data that are similar how
do you define groups and how do you
define similar so if you're partitioning
you've got some pretty hard constraints
and you want it across that they're
balanced and that's maybe more important
than the fact that everything within
each cluster or partition is exactly the
same that's easy in theory that's hard
in practice we're gonna walk through
some examples of what common clustering
algorithms do on a two-dimensional data
set so two-dimensional data
human eye is really good at clustering
we can look at that nil I know what
those clusters are I'm done no problems
this will this allow your intuition to
jive with what the MIS algorithms are
doing you've been looking at this for a
few minutes you probably already know
what the clusters are so let's move off
and look at k-means it's the first
algorithm everyone learns it's one of
the most obvious great that's probably
not what most of you were thinking when
you looked at this data of what the
clusters are so what k-means is doing is
its throwing case centers down in your
space and then it's iterative lis moving
them around your space
to minimize in truck cluster distance
and maximize inter cluster distance so
that's got a couple of disadvantages the
one everyone knows is you have to choose
K like oh I have to pick my number of
centers what if I don't know how to pick
my number of centers that's a little
hard to do there's some work you can do
to work around that a slightly more
subtle disadvantage is that it's a
centroid based technique so at the end
of the day every point got allocated to
the center that was closest to it and
that's a Gaussian ball assumption not
saying my clusters are sphericals so now
spiracle clusters might exist for some
data they probably don't exist from the
general concept of data and assuming
that all of your data is spherical is
kind of like assuming spherical cows not
a great idea in general lastly we've
allocated every single point to a
cluster so this is the assumption that
your partitioning instead of clustering
so that's saying hey there's no noise
there is no background all of my data is
clean and lovely this is taking a square
peg at hammering it into a round hole so
let's move on and look at something else
affinity propagation looks surprisingly
similar to k-means there's a reason for
that that's the last step of affinity
propagation is going to be one iteration
of k-means but affinity propagation is
kind of interesting and that every point
is going to vote on the exemplars enter
that they feel best represents them this
is kind of a cool ideas it allows you
get non symmetric similarity measures
alright my similar did you can be
different than your similarity to me
that's a really nice feature and you
don't have to choose a number of
clusters the disadvantages is there's
another parameter that you do have to
tweak the results are very similar some
very sensitive to that other parameter
the other word disadvantage is slow and
the final disadvantage is you ran
k-means at the end which means spherical
cows square pegs they came right back in
you partitioned and you've got these
spherical clusters okay moving on mean
shift mean shifts an interesting
algorithm you're going to initialize
your space with K centroids and then
you're going to sort of estimate the
local density around
space and each of those centroids is
going to do a hill climb to the local
Maxima so you're going to find these
modes or regions of high density then
you're gonna allocate every or the
points that are dense and near it to
that cluster so one advantage is that
you get those black points so those are
the points in the low density areas so
you say hey I got noise I'm not going to
assume that all of my data has to be
dense or has to be within a cluster
which is great I got rid of my square
peg unfortunately I still have my
spherical cow assumption so I have balls
in my space all right we are on I did
awesome spectral clustering instead then
spectral clustering is nice spectral
clustering says hey I've got really high
dimensional data but maybe it lives on a
low dimensional manifold now think of
that as like a two-dimensional surface
floating through let's say a three
dimensional space if I'm going to
compute distances there maybe I don't
want to compute them in the three
dimensional space I want to talk about
them moving along this surface so to do
that we'll typically approximate our
data with a K nearest neighbor graph and
then have my distances moving along the
graph and so we'll look at the adjacency
matrix of that use a little bit of
linear algebra embed that into a low
dimensional vector space and perform a
clustering on in that low dimensional
space the issue there is typically what
people do in that low dimensional space
is run k-means and enter spherical cows
and the square pegs birch balanced
iterative reducing and clustering using
hierarchies okay so what birch is gonna
do is it's going to iteratively
partition your data up into this sort of
tree it's a cluster feature tree think
that sort of like a B+ tree that's this
sort of dynamically being updated and
growing and now once we've broken our
data up into these trees we're gonna
look at the leaves of the trees the
leaves of the trees represent sort of
groupings of your data we're gonna put
tiny spherical cows around each of the
those leaves then we're going to run
another clustering algorithm usually
k-means
to cluster the spherical cows into large
spherical cows and this is what you get
on the advantage it's fast it's got low
memory a little memory consumption it's
streaming and you don't have to specify
the number of clusters it does have a
parameter that's a little bit hard to
tweak okay enough of centroid based
clustering algorithms I think we were
all seeing a recurrent theme of
spherical cows coming across here all
right hierarchical clustering or we're
gonna talk about specifically
agglomerative clustering this is where
you say all right I'm gonna take all my
data points when I take the two nearest
ones merge them together and I'm just
gonna repeat that over and over again
now to do that meaningfully I have to
come up with some definition of distance
between groups of points so however you
define that distance between groups of
points is going to define what kind of
clusters you're looking for so single
linkage clusters clustering will allow
you to get these long spindly snake-like
clusters coming out complete linkage
clustering is going to get us spherical
cow clusters coming out Ward is sort of
a statistical method that generates
statistically spherical cows the
advantages of this is that some of the
methods don't constrain the shape of
your clusters which is kind of nice you
might not have to go cows that's great
the other is you don't need to slug clay
okay so this gives you all possible K in
a dendrogram or a large tree so it has
lots of hierarchical information about
how your clusters merge and split and
that's great if you have more than a few
thousand points that vendor Graham looks
horrible it's a black mess if anyone's
ever tried to do that in Python and or R
and choosing the cut at that tree which
is akin to choosing your number of
clusters can be quite difficult to do
that being said if you've got small or
medium amounts of data and you think
there's a lot of hierarchical structure
within your data this is an excellent
technique to choose
all right VB scan is the last of the
algorithms I'll talk about it quickly
there's a density based clustering
algorithm it tries to find regions of
your space that are dense surrounded by
region space that are not dense so
whether right the way they're gonna do
that is I'm going to put balls of a
fixed size or and every one of your
points count the number of other points
that are contained within the ball
that's going to be how dense the local
region of that individual point is and
now I'm just gonna look for contiguous
regions of very dense points so that
allows me to have these gray and black
points in the background because they're
outliers they're not contained with any
of these dense regions it also allows me
to have arbitrarily shaped clusters or
these dense regions you still have a
parameter a couple of parameters to
choose from one is that size of that
ball that you need to do a lot of work
to adjust over to find quote-unquote
right solution so here you see we've
merged some clusters that we probably
shouldn't have but overall it looks
fairly good now we've done all of these
searching and the parameter searching
seems to have come up repeatedly and
that's easy ish to do in a low
dimensional space and that's gonna get
harder to do when you can't visualize
your data and look at so what makes this
all so hard all right what makes a good
clustering good how do you tell so
there's lots of different measures for
goodness of clustering that are out
there
chrysten Hennig gave a great talk at PI
data London 2016 highly recommend you
all go out and look at it you could look
at inter cluster separation inter
cluster homogeneity you could look at
density you can look at uniform cluster
sizes lots and lots of different things
there's probably a different goodness
measure for every clustering algorithm
out there and then you publish the paper
that shows that you're better than
everyone else via your distance measure
that's a good secret what a good
clustering algorithm is and what a good
measure is depends on what your
algorithm needs what you need for your
application alright so here's some
slides that are straight stolen from
Krishna 10xtalk
and this is a the best possible three
clustering if you're trying to minimize
inter cluster distance so you can look
at that and some of you will say yes
that's the best clustering that's
exactly what I want my clustering to be
doing
via a different distance measure that's
the best clustering so I'm not saying
one is better than the other but for
everyone in the room you need to decide
which one you liked better and then
figure out why you liked it better for
your application I happen to like this
one better and I'll go into that in a
little more detail soon all right
what is a cluster well what do I mean by
cluster that's maybe an easier question
to answer I tend to use clustering for
doing EDA
or finding interesting regions in my
data exploring my data summarizing what
my data sort of contains so I have a
particular application in mind when I
talk about this you will probably have a
different one yourself I'll start
looking about what I don't want to do
I'm surprised we have these spherical
clusters your clusters don't need to be
balls straight up spiracle cows they
don't need it
spectral clustering you can see this
region in the bottom right corner those
are all cluster that's all one red
cluster so this is the partitioning
problem again not every point in your
clock in your data needs to be in a
cluster real data has noise
we've got measurement error we've got
sampling error we have plain old data
corruption lots of things can can make
this change one of your applications
might be partitioning but if that's not
an explicit requirement of your
application you probably shouldn't use
this square picker sub peg assumption
all right this was the best of the bunch
for my definition what was their
definition of clustering sorry clusters
are dense areas separated by less dense
areas all right I I can't think of
another really good notion that drives
with mind very well but everyone's data
is special unique just like every
snowflake that's what I mean when I talk
about clustering
you should think really hard about what
you mean before you do any clustering
whatsoever back to my definition can we
move more specific about density based
clustering
so we've panned waved a definition let's
get something a little more detailed a
cluster is a connecting component of a
level set of the probability density
function of the underlying and unknown
distribution for which our data sample
are drawn what all right let's walk
through that a little more slowly get a
little bit of intuition going on that
was the data set we've been looking at
all day I can do a sort of a kernel
density estimation and estimate the
probability density function from which
that data was drawn so I've got a heat
map over top of that showing denser
regions in blue colors so that says I'm
drawing data from this region I'm more
likely to draw points of the blue areas
all right so I can cut that in contour
sets these are just areas of equal
probability density now I can grab one
of those contour sets say all right that
makes a cut I can look at all the points
that fall within one of those lassos or
cuts no problems there's my clustering
it jives well with my intuition does
that process a clustering algorithm well
there's a couple of problems there that
say it might not be a clustering
algorithm we don't know that underlying
probability density function that I
magically hand waved and showed you heat
now that a map of at the beginning we
didn't know which levels that's to
choose I and carefully went through
those and chose the exact right level
set to give you a nice driving intuition
for what that was doing and the
computational complexity of doing either
of those tasks is actually quite large
so if I've got a great clustering
algorithm that only works on a thousand
data points that might be useful for
some applications but in general we
would like clustering algorithms to be
able to scale to very large scales
millions of data points and beyond so
what can we do and to talk about what we
can do practically speaking I'm going to
pass this over to my colleague Leland
there you go
alright thanks John so John handles the
statistics and machine learning I'm
really not in that field as much I do
math and programming so I'm interested
in the practicalities of what we can
actually do in practice so first dip
that into the approximation that's a
hard thing to do I don't want to
approximate density all across the whole
space that's incredibly computationally
expensive
I want to approximate density locally
just around points so here's what DB
scan does it has two parameters has
epsilon and midpoints and it draws balls
of radius epsilon and declares any
points that have balls with at least men
points in them to be dense so here I
drew a whole bunch of circles of varying
of a fixed radius and I colored them red
if they had more than three points in
them gray otherwise so you can see it's
picking out the higher density areas
there nicely I've found the red dense
regions quite well okay that's also very
fast to compute and it's sort of local
to each point so you can do that fairly
efficiently but let's turn it on its
head a little bit what if we draw
circles of whatever radius we need to
manage to contain min points many points
in other words for each point we're
gonna take the radius that would be
required for Dede scan to declare the
point dense so i've done that and i've
now shaded those circles with a color
according to how large their radius is
the larger the radius the light lighter
the color down into sort of greens and
yellows okay I can translate that onto
the points and I seem to have colored
the points with relatively their
relative density so that's nice
I've got a very cheap estimate of the
probability density function over the
points that's great so now I have to
figure out how I can deal with level
sets there all right so I need to get
some level sets and pick out what you're
the right level says so how am I going
to do that the first step to figuring
out how to do this is to step back a bit
and realize that the level sets are
actually going to form a tree so you can
see this a little more clearly with a
little animation
so let's get this running this is this
is a univariate probability density
function and we're just going to run a
line down of decreasing density and
whenever you pick up a new area I'm
gonna add a branch to my tree whenever I
hit a local minima there I'm gonna merge
together the branches where they meet
until I eventually get a root of the
tree so you can see given a probability
density function you can build a tree
from it so we can do the same thing with
points so what I'm going to do here is
I'm going have circles of increasing
radius about each point remember the
size of the radius is going to be
related to how dense the pointers and
I'm going to color those circles in as
soon as they capture enough points to be
declared dense and then I'm gonna merge
connected regions together with uniform
colors as I go building up this tree so
here we go and you can see color is
popping up and then merging together and
now we're down to just three colors
eventually the blue and the purple look
at emerge in a minute once they connect
up with each other there and then
finally the green pops in and we're at
the root of their tree so we can build
up a tree of varying density okay if we
can get a tree of density can we play
our game to select out the cluster from
that yeah there's a make sense a mess
algorithm that'll select out clusters
from a tree so this is this is not so
bad now I can select out the level sets
I want so it's managing to basically
pull out flat clustering from the tree
so what does this look like in practice
so here's our familiar data set if we
run this on this data set what sort of
tree do we get we get this now that that
is actually a tree there's actually lots
and lots and lots of little branches in
there but it's just solid black because
there's so many of them it's hard to
make any sense of it so one more trick
here to try to make this a little easier
to do so the trick we're gonna play is
that in practice almost all of those
splits in this vast complicated tree are
one or two points dropping out of a
cluster or joining a cluster depending
on which way you want to look at it and
for many purposes that's that's not
really splitting into two clusters I
don't really think one point is a
separate cluster I have some notion of
granularity of how big a cluster could
be I have a midden cluster size so as
long as I don't move as long as the
split involves less than that mini
cluster size number of points falling
out I'm going to say the cluster
persists rather than splitting in two
and I just lost some points from that
cluster so if I go through and run that
process through on the whole tree it
simplifies the tree down because now
most of those splits are not actually
splitting apart as a tree they're just a
single cluster losing some points so if
we simplify the tree down this is what
we get now this is a tree you can
actually look at and understand it make
sense all at least reasonably so err
tree is much simpler and the width of
each branch is related to the number of
points I've also colored them that way
it so you can see that there are points
falling out of the clusters as they go
down the page and what you want to do to
sort of pick out the flat clustering is
effectively maximize the amount of ink
so the the constraint is that if you
choose a cluster you can't choose any of
its children and so subject to that
constraint you're just going to work
through and try and choose the clusters
that will basically get you the most
amount of ink on the page so to speak
the excess of mass so this is what that
algorithm picks out as the clusters now
as it happens there's a single flat cut
there that would actually pick out all
of those clusters but there's actually
no reason for that to necessarily be the
case now on a different data set with
clusters of wildly varying density it
can pick out something that picks out a
cluster of way up high in the tree and
another cluster way down low in the tree
where there's no single flat cut that
would get you there it will handle
variable density cuts very nicely and so
what's the result of doing this cluster
here's what that algorithm provides and
this is what I wanted when I first
stared at that data the black points
again our noise points that's
considering those outliers and then the
rest it's picking out the clusters very
very tightly so this is the HDB scan
clustering algorithm it was
very recent from two papers from
Campello moola v sander and zurich in
2013 2015 and it's an excellent
clustering algorithm for just getting
things right off the bat so what about
performance because that was a nice
looking clustering but we made it at
least computable but how computable is
that how well can we scale out well the
first thing is that I don't want to run
connected components for every level of
that tree that's too hard to do that's
too expensive we can frame the problem
as connected components in a graph which
improves things a little but better
still we can find the video spanning
tree of that graph whose that minimum
spanning tree is literally the edges
that cause disconnections of components
in the graph so the minimum spanning
tree actually contains all the
information to rebuild that cluster tree
so there's a very small number of edges
in the graph that are actually the
critical ones and we just have to figure
out which ones those are and then we can
reconstruct the entire tree from that
straight away so the next catch is that
the graph we would be doing this on
turns out to be a complete graph so
traditional minimum spanning tree
algorithms such as friends and kruskal's
have order n-squared asymptotics on a
complete graph there they're designed
for graphs with relatively small numbers
of edges compared to the number of nodes
we're dealing with a graph that has n
squared edges where you've got your
nodes so that's not going to cut it we
we can't really afford an N squared
algorithm so what can we do we can use
spatial indexing so generally speaking
that some sort of tree that divides up
the space in a sort of recursive manner
so that you can ignore effects of things
that are a long way apart and only worry
about things that are close together so
by that I mean things like quad trees or
octrees KD trees Bowl trees there's a
whole slew of different notions of doing
this generally we use KD trees and Bal
trees
but you can think of whatever tree
structure for space that you you prefer
to thinking so the main thing that
spatial indexing provides is that it's
really fast for nearest-neighbor queries
if I want to find the nearest neighbor
of a point I can basically run through
that tree and ignore all the points that
are really far away and only worry about
the points that the closest to that
point that I'm querying and that means I
can query for the nearest neighbor of a
point in order log in instead of
ordering I don't have to look at how far
it is away from all the points in that
I've set just the ones in that in the
sort of closest few leaves of the tree
so if we use blue of course algorithm
for minimum spanning trees the upside of
this is that we can actually pretty much
turn our minimums beat spanning tree
computation into a whole bunch of
repeated nearest neighbor queries
there's some caveats on that but in
practice they actually make the
algorithm run a little faster so we can
take the dual tree brew of K algorithm
that was by March Raymond gray in 2010
and we can get order in login
performance from minimum spanning tree
computations which is the bulk of the
HDD scan algorithm so we can convert HDD
scan from any n squared algorithm as it
was first published into an inaugural
rhythm that we can run in practice so
what does that mean in terms of actual
clustering performance here's a whole
bunch of clustering algorithms including
many other ones we looked at at the
start and as you can see they quickly
fall into two categories ones that are
actually practicable along reasonable
sized datasets and the others so let's
worry about the ones that look
practicable will extend out the x-axis
look at clustering more points and
there's there's fewer here and HDD scan
with air in log in implementation is
down there in the dark green at the very
bottom here we can extend that out one
more time
and now you can see that HDD scan
despite effectively computing DB scan
for every possible epsilon parameter
value he's running faster than SK learns
DB scan so we can actually do this
extremely efficiently and scale to
fairly large amounts of data now in
practice what can you do well if you
don't
interactively you know on the order of a
hundred thousand points if you want to
do it overnight you can get to five
million maybe even ten million points
okay that was good can we do better
so the biggest annoyance that I still
have is that I still need to choose this
number of points value for the density
estimate how many points do I have to
enclose within my epsilon ball before I
can declare a point dense now we went
from DBC and HDD scan by sort of
computing things for all possible
epsilon values so we sort of varied over
the whole parameter range and then it
integrated everything together can we
play the same trick can we vary the min
points parameter the same way we vary
dip so on and integrate everything
together well no there's no obvious way
to convert that through but topology to
the rescue said no one until now
probably you can think of building the
initial HDD scan tree in terms of
something called persistent homology if
you're familiar with that great if
you're not don't panic it's just a tool
from algebraic topology and the main
thing is that it gives us a very clean
simple mathematical description of
what's going on even better once we're
embracing this topological framework
which you should do anyway
we get other algebraic topology tools to
bring to bear on the problem and one of
them is it's fairly recent
multi-dimensional persistent homology
that came out in about 2008 that
actually lets you do persistent homology
over a multiple variables so we could
persist over epsilon and mend points at
the same time so if we can frame our
problem in terms of multi-dimensional
Pacific persistent homology maybe we can
get what we want the catch is that the
result of doing that is not a nice
structure like persistent and what would
you give you where you get a tree in
fact you get well a really complicated
thing that's hard to wrap your head
around so our whole little game that we
played with the tree to sort of pick out
the clusters at the end that's not
available to us anymore
the upside is we can if you want
completely rethink HDB's en andrey
described it all in terms of sheaves
instead of trees now I'm not gonna get
into sheaves in this talk please come
check with me after if you actually care
and we're getting into some deep
theoretical waters here which I like
because I finally get to use all that
category theory and tapas theory that I
learned you know shout out to Gotham to
eat apologies I've they're actually
finding a practical use in reality the
main thing is that this just gives us
the right data structure mentally to
solve this problem the right data
structure and practice is probably not
going to be this but that's okay it's a
way to think about the problem so the
the key is that the resulting algorithm
of HDTV scan in terms of sheaves does
generalize to the multi-dimensional case
there's some caveats on that because
whenever you're generalizing from a
simple case up to a more complicated one
you inevitably have the difficulty that
there are a couple of different ways the
generalization could go that's okay we
all have to figure out the details on
that yet and when we get that done
that's going to be preserved in density
clustering and we're going to get some
advantages here the main ones are it's
gonna be even more robust there's fewer
parameters you're just gonna have to
pick them in cluster size and in
practice we can actually get similar
performance same asymptotics the
constants are going to be a little worse
otherwise all the sudden so what are the
conclusions and and what do I want you
to take away from this talk what does
John want you to take away from this
talk well the first one is k-means
should not be your first choice for
clustering we really want to emphasize
that k-means shouldn't be your second
choice for clustering either the main
thing is that we want you to think
really hard about what cluster means for
your application what do you need
clustering to do because that really
influences which algorithms make sense
for your problem and while you're
thinking about it you may as well run
HDV scan it's probably what you want to
do anyway
all right thank you are there any
questions yeah okay so the the question
was about the curse of dimensionality
and I think the short answer is that I
don't think clustering is practical in
really high dimensions because I don't
think it makes sense distances cease to
be meaningful really in truly high
dimensional spaces so I would say that
the answer is that you need a
dimensional reduction technique before
you can cluster if your data is living
in a high dimensional space and in a
truly high dimensional space and there's
natively in that high dimensional space
there isn't some low dimensional
manifold that you can pull out there are
no clusters there there's no meaning
there if your data is in a high
dimensional space on a low dimensional
manifold dimensional reduction of some
form will work and then you can cluster
other questions yeah Oh Tina Mitchell
data for the Chinese team dimensional
data further for the timings and we in
practice I think you can get to fifty or
hundred dimensional it's not too bad but
HDTV scan data scale badly with
dimensionality if you get truly high
dimensional data it's going to take a
lot longer to run that is very true that
yeah for this code base that is up on
the slides here that you can pip install
comments or whatever you need that is
all inside them so it compiles down to C
for the fundamental data structures yes
it takes advantage so the question is
does it take advantage of multi-core
ultimately fundamentally it's single
threaded it does take advantage of more
cores where it can but the algorithm
itself is hard to paralyze well that
would be an interesting area of research
I'd love to talk to you more if you have
thoughts on that yeah so I know you said
this precision it's a cluster a
two-story code but you kind of have an
idea of how that might tie it up this is
a persistent homology like topological
data analysis kind of things that happen
yeah well certainly I think I think
persistent homology is a really
interesting idea that's still trying to
find a really really good application
personally I think this is potentially
one of those good applications now I'm
not using anywhere near the full power
of persistent homology I'm only
interested in the zeroth component but
it's where the tools of persistent
homology have realized theoretical value
in a practical setting and I think there
are going to be more cases of that but I
think it's going to be time will tell
yep what is your recommendation to
handle situations when individual
dimensions have very varying scales
organizations what's your take on that
well that's actually a pretty difficult
problem to be honest John do you have
thoughts on that so then you're talking
into two dimension reduction techniques
so if you're looking across the center
dimension reduction techniques how to
properly do standardization across your
individual variables before collapsing
down into space so there are so that you
can always do the standard center
centering and basic statistical
techniques there's some really
interesting work coming out of a
generalized low-rank model paper that
came out of Stanford recently with Odell
at all who are talking about the right
centering methodology for dealing with
heterogeneous data and I would I would
jump in that direction if you were
looking for something sort of cutting
edge and experimental